antenne de 20h le journal de la
rédaction
henri sannier bonsoir le premier
ministre et cinq chefs de partis à la
recherche d'un consensus
en toile de fond financement
transparence et moralisation de la vie
politique dans quelques instants
déclaration en direct analyse
les premiers commentaires
amiens mort du militant cgt blessés au
cours d'une manifestation la victime
âgée de 61 ans avait sombré dans le coma
à la suite de heurts avec la police
prison ferme for eric ramenait le
coureur cycliste convaincu de trafic de
produits dopants ses complices médecins
et pharmaciens condamnés à des peines
d'interdiction professionnelle
émotion et colère en israël à la suite
d'un raid meurtrier sur un camp
militaire l'opération suicide revendiqué
par une organisation palestinienne a
fait six morts et sept blessés
une journée supplémentaire de détention
pour marcel carton
marcel fontaine jean paul kauffmann jean
louis normandin d'antenne 2 et roger
auque les otages français au liban n'ont
toujours pas été libérés
la mort d'un homme à la une du journal
amiens dans la somme on a du mal ce soir
à cacher sa colère et surtout son
émotion
quelques heures après le décès d'un
retraité grièvement blessé lors d'une
manifestation
l' affaire remonte au 6 novembre dernier
ce jour là lucien barbier 62 ans
militant cgt et membre du parti
communiste manifesté devant le palais
des congrès d'amiens
l'histoire d'une tragédie à travers une
manifestation des affrontements est
aujourd'hui la mort françois joly lucien
barbier est décédé cet après midi à
l'hôpital d'amiens après 20 jours de
coma il souffrait d'une fracture du
crâne il avait été grièvement blessé
lors de violents affrontements entre
manifestants et forces de l'ordre le 6
novembre dernier à amiens
la cgt protesté ce jour là contre la
politique économique du gouvernement
la violence de la répression policière
avait suscité de vives réactions de la
cgt contre manifestation plainte pour
coups et blessures mais aujourd'hui
après l'annoncé du décès de lucien
barbier cette affaire a pris une
dimension nationale au palais beau bourg
cet après midi les députés ont suspendu
leurs travaux pendant cinq minutes en
hommage à ce syndicaliste force ouvrière
le snes la cgt police ce soir font par
eux aussi de leur indignation
enfin henri krasucki a annoncé que la
cgt organiserait un hommage national
amiens samedi pour les obsèques de
lucien mardi voilà la cgt donc je
confirme annonce un hommage national le
groupe communiste au sénat a demandé une
minute de silence en hommage à lucien
barbier le pcf dénonce je cite la chasse
à l'homme organisée par la police de
monsieur chirac et de monsieur pasqua
fin de citation le snes appelle à la
manifestation qui était prévu d'ailleurs
depuis quelques jours par la cgt
pour le 30 novembre et annonce qu'elle
prend contact avec la fen et la cgt
voilà tout ce que l'on peut dire ce soir
au niveau des réactions
le financement des partis politiques
n'est plus un sujet tabou
cet après midi à l'hôtel matignon les
principaux responsables politiques se
sont retrouvés autour d'une table pour
mettre à plat toutes les propositions
cinq personnalités autour de jacques
chirac pour une réunion qui s'est
déroulé à huis clos
c'est donc dans la cour de l'hôtel
matignon que nous avons glané nos
premières informations reportages en lui
le scène rachid arhab les écologistes
n'étaient pas invités à partager le
gâteau des cinq grands alors les verts
ont apporté leurs quatre heures un
énorme gâteau garni de pièces en
chocolat que deux candidats écologistes
antoine waechter a accepté de partager
symboliquement avec l'autre exclu la
réunion pierre jules gâteau est destiné
et destinées à entrer aller à l'hôtel
matignon je crois qu'on va pas le
démonter leurs noms mais milka même une
petite pièce symboliquement de toute
façon moi je devais la pêche et bientôt
avec personne il s'agit pas de faire
mieux qu'elle s'enlève ya l'air si
j'adore le chocolat c'est un
antidépresseur puissant
seuls les chefs des partis représentés à
l'assemblée étaient conviés à rencontrer
le premier ministre un peu plus de deux
heures de réunion au cours de laquelle
jacques chirac a surtout écouté des
leaders politiques français
le premier à quitter matignon sera à
jean marie le pen très pressé par le
temps et les journaux du jura qui n'a
pas dit grand chose
une discussion très libre a ajouté
lionel jospin pressé lui aussi mais
souriant souriant comme jean le camus
est satisfait un accord je n'ose pas
dire unanime
j'espère qu'il sera assez large c'est
l'effort brive et un optimisme que ne
partage visiblement pas georges marchais
le leader du parti communiste n'est pas
sûr d'assister à la prochaine réunion de
ce genre il aurait voulu que l'on y
parle finances mais aussi et médias
assassiné si vous me demandez si nous
parviendrons à un accord
ça me semble extrêmement difficile le
plus satisfait à la sortie de la réunion
était sans nul doute jacques toubon pour
le rpr l'entretien d'aujourd'hui est une
avancée manquent eux il y a
indiscutablement à partir de cette
réunion un progrès
prochaine réunion dans une quinzaine de
jours c'est en tout cas ce qu'a annoncé
l'hôtel matignon en début de soirée et
oui apparemment tout le monde souhaite
aller vite au nom d'une certaine
moralisation de la vie politique nous y
reviendrons dans quelques instants en
compagnie de nos invités jean lecanuet
qui est à mes côtés sur le plateau et
lionel jospin qui répondra à nos
questions en direct de toulouse je vois
que tout le monde est prêt avant cela
voyons rapidement les données du
problème et surtout les solutions
proposées pour le résoudre
vous allez voir que le mot transparence
n'a pas la même signification pour tout
le monde
olivier lerner cinq chefs de partis
réunis autour de jacques chirac
en théorie tout le monde est d'accord
mais dans la pratique
bonjour les divergences premier exemple
le financement public des partis
le front national et pour le rpr et le
parti communiste sont contre l'udf et le
parti socialiste n'ont pas encore arrêté
leur position
deuxième exemple la transparence du
patrimoine tout à fait pour le ps et le
pc pour mais sous réserve le rpr et
l'udf contre mais sous réserve
le front national troisième exemple la
question du plafonnement des dépenses
la cellule a limité le club des cinq et
pur à 100%
cette réunion n'est que la première
d'une longue série premier épisode
premier tour d'horizon mais rien n'est
réglé pour autant
et les présidentielles approchent chaque
candidat sait qu'il aura à recueillir de
100 à 200 millions de francs
200 millions en toute transparence bien
évidemment en deux mots jean lecanuet le
climat de la rencontre je me suis laissé
dire par quelques indiscrétions que
c'était plutôt froid au départ un oui au
départ c'était un peu guindée empesé
mais après tout c'était six français
autour d'une table et moi j'ai trouvé
agréable que la conversation puisse
établir eu un peu de polémique ou par
certains patrons
lionel jospin un mot de l'ambiance le
courant est passé entre les cinq ténors
je devrai c'était un peu froid au début
et puis
nous avons plus nous parler comme dans
toute réunion je sais un petit peu
détendu de toute façon les problèmes
étaient sérieux changements
manifestement pardon il ya eu un échange
de vues
je vous entends mal à un lionel jospin
vous m'entendez mal ça va un peu mieux
la j'espère que les téléspectateurs
romands tendent récents problèmes ça y
est ça ma c'est parce que je suis à
toulouse veut plus loin tout à fait dans
votre circonscription à en haute garonne
dans la circonscription haute garonne
pour le moment oui nous avons pu parler
effectivement vous avez parlé à vis clos
vous allez faire devant les
téléspectateurs comme ça à l'air très
confus en quelques mots patrimoine des
hommes politiques
d'accord pas d'accord monsieur n'ose pas
pour la transparence des patrimoines des
hommes politiques le parti socialiste
les socialistes sont d'accord et cela a
paru d'ailleurs un des points sur
lesquels les différences étaient les
moins mais sur le canut et assure la
déclaration du patrimoine d'un candidat
à la présidence de la république et des
élus importants
je crois que nous allons vers un accord
ce qu'il faut c'est que les français
sachent si un homme politique est
honnête ou s'ils profitent abusivement
des moyens financiers qui sont ceux des
contribuables
c'est ça que cette transparence là qui
est nécessaire et je crois qu'on va
arriver à un accord
deuxième point monsieur jospin
limitation des dépenses pour la campagne
électorale d'accord pas d'accord
électorale nous sommes venus nous les
socialistes je suis venu avec l'idée
d'un accord mais j'ai dit aussi que cela
n'était pas suffisant il ne suffisait
pas de plafonner il fallait aussi sur ce
point et des financièrement à la
campagne des candidats donc oui sur le
plafonnement mais il reste la question
du financement des campagnes alors on va
on va arriver à ce point monsieur lecanu
est il ya toutes les formations
politiques je crois ont proposé c'est le
cas du df en tout état de cause que l'on
freine les abus de propagande
d'affichage de journaux
donc un coup de frein donc un
plafonnement des dépenses et un contrôle
de ce plafonnement troisième point
semble-t-il le plus épineux le
financement des partis alors la
divergence la position de l'udf la
position du df n'est pas une position
sectaire
nous considérons qu'il appartient à
l'état c'est à dire aux contribuables
par l'impôt d'aidé aux campagnes
électorales penser à la prochaine
campagne présidentielle
mais nous pensons qu'il ne faut pas
demander un effort fiscal supplémentaire
aux français pour la vie ordinaire
courante des partis politiques qui eux
doivent vivre de l'aide directe qui leur
vient des personnes qui ont de la
sympathie pour les formations et ça
n'est pas l'avis ne s'agisse pas et
c'est un point sur lequel effectivement
la philosophie du rpr et l'udf telles
que je les comprise mais ça a été une
première discussion et la note sont
différentes et c'est pas tellement
surprenant au fond j'ai compris que les
partis de droite disait il faut pas de
financement public des partis
par contre il faut légaliser les
financements privés et je dirais même
inciter au financement privé des partis
politiques par exemple par des
déductions fiscales
or moi je pense que ce qui pose problème
c'est au contraire le financement privé
soit qu'il soit au culte soit même s'ils
étaient ouverts mais on nous a pas
proposé du côté des partis de droite que
lille soit public qui aura des
déclarations à l'administration des
impôts mais ça ne sera pas connue
publiquement mais féret soi-même pour
soi-même soi même qu'il soit public
parce que c'est le rapport entre les
partis politiques et des grands groupes
par exemple des groupes financiers des
entreprises s compte autres bref s'il
vous plaît veillez à 20 heures c'est un
point essentiel c'est un point essentiel
nous nous souhaitons la moralisation de
la vie publique mais aussi la démocratie
et l'égalité entre les parties et sa
seule le financement public pour
l'assurer parce que le financement privé
il ira toujours au parti de droite car
l'argent va plutôt là où est l'argent
bon on dirait qu'il n'est jamais trop
tard
l'ancienne majorité la majorité
aujourd'hui n'avait pas fait pendant 23
ans les socialistes n'ont plus alors est
ce que il ya vraiment une chance
d'aboutir
ou ce que est ce que c'est un simulacre
compte tenu des scandales qui ont éclaté
ces dernières semaines permettrait de
répondre à monsieur jospin qu il faut
être prudent quand on dit que l'argent
va à l'argent moi je ne perds pas de vue
la grande affaire d'état qui concerne
les trafics d'armes illicites
alors de quoi est il question qui n'y
ait plus de choses cachées les
socialistes préfèrent que le
contribuable finance les parties nous
préférons que ce soit la donation privé
avec une aide fiscale
c'est exactement ce qui se passe pour
les associations où vous pouvez
naturellement sous un plafond très très
limité donner une aide à une association
de votre choix
pourquoi ne pas le faire pour les
formations politiques ce sera clair on
saura qui donne quoi à qui on pourra
dire en 88 tous honnêtes la famille
je vous demande de reprendre de rap
maurras ont je crois que l'honnêteté des
hommes politiques
le plus souvent et heureusement n'est
pas en cause ce qui est en cause c'est
de savoir si on modernise les modes de
financement de notre vie publique comme
ça existe dans les autres démocraties ou
non je crois que c'est ça le problème
et c'est celui - kypreos eu
personnellement me préoccuper préoccupe
le parti socialiste dans le cadre est il
fait plus que me préoccupe et je
rappelle que monsieur raymond barre
quand il était premier ministre sur les
orientations données par monsieur
giscard d'estaing avait présenté un
projet destiné à la transparence de la
vie politique ne faisons donc que
persévérer sur la voie que nous avons
tracée depuis les adultes c'est vrai
merci c'est beau la politique
ah c'est vrai mais pour être exact
monsieur lecanu et se souviendra qu'à
l'époque c'était monsieur seguin et le
rpr qui avait enterré le projet oui mais
monsieur et à la rissala
socialisme le jeu ne soit venir vous
avait écarté le projet non le projet de
l'ars avait au moins le mérite d'exister
on en reste là bas vraisemblablement
paul merci la politique toujours écouté
bien avec un sondage sofres le nouvel
observateur surprise la courbe de
jacques chirac remonte 46% des français
pensent que le premier ministre ferait
un bon président de la république contre
42 pour cent au mois d'octobre
françois mitterrand est toujours
largement en tête avec 62 %
israël victime une nouvelle fois d'une
attaque suicide
l'opération revendiqué aujourd'hui par
le front populaire de libération de la
palestine sheikh ahmad gibril s'est
déroulé hier soir elle a fait sept morts
et plusieurs blessés dans un camp
militaire en haute galilée l'opération
commando menée à partir du sud-liban
s'appuyer sur des ailes volantes
c'est le raid le plus sanglant mené en
israël depuis mars 78 charles enderlin
les choses se sont mal passées pour
l'armée israélienne hier soir les ulm
des palestiniens ont bien été repéré au
dessus du sud liban l'un d'entre eux a
été abattu son pilote est mort mais le
second a réussi à atterrir ici en haute
galilée près de kiryat shmona
l'assaillant a tiré d'abord sur ce
véhicule militaire tuant le chauffeur
puis il a attaqué seule la base
militaire voisine des rafales d'armes
automatiques et des grenades
cinq soldats trouvent la mort sept sont
blessés avant que le palestinien ne soit
tabet jusque vers 10 heures du matin
toute la région a été bouclé pour
permettre un ratissage méticuleux des
deux côtés de la frontière
en tout cas pour les habitants de la
ville de kiryat shmona cette attaque
signifie la fin d'une longue période de
calme il y avait la guerre du liban
on était loin de penser qui va arriver
le premier objectif du gouvernement
israélien est donc de rassurer les
populations civiles
il s'agit à venir le premier ministre
est venu rencontrer les responsables
locaux
nous regrettons les vics en perdez mais
geoffrey rush tout haut que des cas
pareils ne se répète pas
la tension est toujours très vive à la
frontière israélo libanaise et au sud
liban où on attend les mesures que va
prendre israël face à cette nouvelle
menace à paris manifestation
anniversaire un an jour pour jour après
le début de la fronde des lycéens et des
étudiants
plusieurs milliers de jeunes sont
descendus dans la rue cet après midi à
l'appel des jeunesses communistes leur
cheval de bataille aujourd'hui c'était
surtout le budget de l'enseignement
supérieur un budget qui fait dire aux
militants que l'université étant périmés
au-delà de cette manifestation d'autres
images celles de 86 nous reviennent en
mémoire l'image du dérapage tragique des
événements avec la mort de malik
oussékine image d' alain devaquet un
ministre contraint à la démission
un an après édition spéciale ce soir à
22h10 nous propose un autre regard sur
les événements sans nostalgie ni
partialité
vous reverrez tous ceux qui de près ou
de loin ont fait douter le gouvernement
en cette fin d'année 86 vous entendrez
aussi alain devaquet commentaires des
stèles gouzy face à face un an après
alain devaquet redevenu professeur de
chimie eux sont étudiants en première
année de médecine
je n'ai pas eu la moindre appréhension
pendant les événements je n'ai pas eu la
moindre appréhension pénétrant dans cet
amphithéâtre pour mon premier pauvre je
savais
et j'étais certain qu'il n'y aurait
aucune remarque ou qu'un colis mais
lorsque je faisais mon cours ambiance
studieuse un super prof disent les
étudiants sur l'estrade l'homme qui
voulait réformer l'université
tous se souviennent des manifestations
de la violence de l'impossible dialogue
et finalement du retrait du projet avec
nous alain devaquet accepté de revenir
sur ces événements
qu'est ce que vous allez lui terminé on
veut le retrait du projet devaquet les
étudiants voulaient le retrait pur et
simple du texte qui n'était pas je pense
que
collectivement étudiants ou
représentants des étudiants les
ministres réunis
nous avons malheureusement raté une
occasion que je crois que tous les
participants de cette réunion
forst peut-être à des degrés divers tous
une petite part de responsabilité dans
cet échec ce soir 22h10 sur antenne 2 en
haïti recrudescence de la violence
notamment à port au prince depuis lundi
19 personnes ont trouvé la mort et sur
place dans les milieux politiques on se
demande maintenant si le regain de
tension ne va pas remettre en cause les
élections de dimanche prochain
aujourd'hui sept nouvelles personnes ont
été tuées dans différents quartiers de
port au prince
apparemment toutes les violences sont
déclenchées par des groupes armés
proches de l'ancien président duvalier
un climat de violence sournoise
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux martin
laroche joubert et jacques des derniers
jours de fièvre d'une campagne
électorale sous tension 23 candidats
nous sommes ici avec max il défend les
couleurs de théodore mais théodore et
communistes c'est très mal vu dans ce
pays où les macoutes ont longtemps régné
en maître absolu
vengeance hasard quelques heures après
juste à côté l'un des plus grands
marchés de port au prince le marché
salomon flandre les coupables pour les
haïtiens que nous interrogeons ce sont
les macoutes partisans des duvaliéristes
toujours affluent mais rayés des listes
électorales donc prêt à tout la plus
grave provocation de la semaine d'après
max c'est comme ça qu'ils essayent
d'utiliser le crêpes et de faux débats
et côté les élections mais je crois que
ça montre la complicité de l'armée dans
cette affaire parce qu'il ya
impossibilité à pas loin d'ici
vous étiez là et qui a fait ça
une armée et des policiers qui ferment
les yeux
chaque matin des cadavres sur les
trottoirs des maisons incendiées
la plupart des magasins de la capitale
restent fermés la timide à sion demeure
la seule arme des duvaliéristes pour
empêcher les élections
mais les premiers visés sont ici dans
une bâtisse transformant bancaire par
les membres du conseil électoral
provisoire
c'est le conseil qui organise le
contrôle les élections il tranchera
aussi en cas de conflit une position de
tous les dangers pour son président
emmanuel ambroise conditions chaque soir
je dors dans un endroit différent je
suis littéralement tracté par les
assassins du régime déchu
la police refuse de s'en mêler et c'est
la meilleure façon pour l'amour pour la
police de paralyser les opérations
électorales
c'est un affectant de ne pas se mêler du
bon déroulement des élections dépend
l'avenir politique des haïtiens un
avenir chargé d'incertitudes apparaît
difficile dans un pays sans habitude
démocratique
dimanche pour la première fois depuis
trente ans les haïtiens éliront leur
président frédéric aurillac militants
d'ultragauche pro-palestiniens une
nouvelle fois la une de l'actualité
interpellé lundi dernier en bretagne à
rennes aurillac est toujours en garde à
vue
on vient d'apprendre que les policiers
de la dst aurait retrouvé chez lui un
certain nombre de documents leur
importance pourrait être décisive le
point avec hervé brusini qui avait t-il
précisément dans la maison de frédéric
orillac de la documentation ou une liste
de futures cibles de fait après la
perquisition des enquêteurs de la dst
une trentaine de fiches ont été
découvertes sur chacune l'identité la
fonction parfois même la description
physique de magistrats de policiers même
de journalistes tous spécialistes de
l'antiterrorisme également un plan
détaillé du palais de justice de paris
pour les avocats du militant d'extrême
gauche tout cela devait servir à la
thèse que rédige actuellement la femme
de leur client une information
judiciaire a pourtant été ouverte contre
frédéric orillac pour association de
malfaiteurs ses démêlés avec la justice
ne s'arrête d'ailleurs pas là
après une récente décision de la cour de
cassation sur un dossier qui remonte à
aurillac pourrait avoir à purger un an
de prison le sport très vite à
sestrières en italie avec la première
épreuve de la coupe du monde de ski
alpin des routes pour l'équipe de france
puisque on ne trouve aucune française
dans les dix premières victoires de
l'espagnole blanca à fernandes ochoa 2
avant la yougoslave mateja svet et la
suissesse vanish ryder alan verdict dans
le procès du dopage pour la première
fois un sportif est condamné à un
emprisonnement gens et oui ce procès est
exemplaire alors il est exemplaire mais
il est aussi dans ses condamnations
elles ont frappé les utilisateurs les
coureurs mais surtout les fournisseurs
les médecins et les pharmaciens plus que
le procédé dopé c'est à dire les
victimes
il est surtout le procès du dopage en
général et en cela il est encore
exemplaire nous allons voir avec des
images le seul condamné à la prison
ferme est un coureur cycliste il
s'appelle eric ramené à l'énoncé du
verdict il a perdu son sang froid et
s'en est pris à un journaliste il vient
d'écoper de deux mois de prison ferme et
16 avec sursis pour falsification de
ordonnance et trafic de tony dron un
millier d'emplois son pharmacien alfred
pas vous aujourd'hui en retraite a été
condamné à trois ans de prison avec
sursis une forte amende
son médecin le docteur bador le livreur
ordonnance à dix mois de prison avec
sursis une forte amende et
l'interdiction professionnelle geste de
clémence du tribunal en faveur des
autres inculpés 61 au total mais ce qui
n'a pas empêché le président du tribunal
d'insister sur le manque de rigueur
confessionnelles et la complaisance de
certains médecins le football avec une
belle image qui se ternit
malheureusement tous ceux qui comme moi
ont vibré aux exploits du grand fleury
di nallo tombe très aujourd'hui le petit
prince de gerland comme on l'appelait
est en prison pour trafic de cartes
bleues l'ex numéro un du football a mal
négocié sa sa reconversion à celles
moins que l'on puisse dire oui fleury
dit lafleur est ce soir en vase clos à
la prison de lyon accusé d'un trafic de
cartes bleues un trafic qui portait sur
plusieurs centaines de milliers de
francs alors fleury di nallo depuis sa
retraite sportive en 1979 et est resté
tout de même dans le milieu du football
nous allons le voir nous allons le
retrouver plus tôt maintenant et il
était depuis 1983
entraîneur d'une petite équipe de
mérieux dans l'ain c'est ce matin qu'il
a été inculpé en compagnie de son épouse
et de 13 autres personnes
ce joueur autrefois aux dribbles
étourdissant au temps de sa splendeur
internationale dans les années 70 n'a
pas réussi à tromper cette fois les
policiers lyonnais
le trafic était simple à partir d'une
carte bleue volée il facturait des
marchandises qu'il ne livrait jamais
mais la banque régler l'addition et même
l'indemnité après déclaration de vol
fleury di nallo a donc perdu son 414e
match celui du retour à la vie normale
dommage si vous êtes amateur de bastia
et rendez vous important ce soir sur
antenne 2 à partir de 23h55 que vous
pourrez suivre salonique orthez un match
qui compte pour la poule finale du
championnat d'europe des clubs champions
c'est tout pour le sport la météo neige
en france scènes de panique
malheureusement aux philippines aux
dernières nouvelles le typhon mina
aurait fait plus de 200 morts et de
nombreux disparus
les communications sont coupées avec
certaines régions il y à 400 km au sud
de manille
sur place les vents ont dépassé 200
kilomètres/heure chez-nous laurent les
images sont différentes nous parle
d'accalmie voilà on parle d' apaisement
d'ailleurs le typhon aussi s'est apaisée
je tiens à le dire puisque nous avons eu
des informations à quelques minutes ils
soufflent maintenant au large de manille
à 30 km heure seulement ça c'est fort
bien passé donc au large des côtes
philippines
en france c'est l'apaisement on vous
savez bien nous avions les nerfs en
boule en tout cas l'automne avait les
nerfs en boule en boule de neige bien
sûr mais après la crise de nerfs après
la dépression voici venu maintenant
l'heure de l'accalmie et vous allez en
juger par la poussée d'un anticyclone
enfin que je vais d'abord je vais tracé
voyez les quelques éclaircies que nous
aurons dans la journée de demain sur les
côtes atlantiques avec l'anticyclone qui
est ici et qui donc va commencer à
gonfler à grignoter un peu de terrain en
direction
ben de l'intérieur de nos terres mais ça
n'est pas encore le cas bien sûr ça va
certes progressivement jusqu'à dimanche
donc demain nous aurons des éclaircies
le long des côtes atlantiques nous
aurons aussi encore quelques chutes de
neige mais sur ce les massifs montagneux
que je vous indique la et puis partout
d'ailleurs un ciel gris un ciel uniforme
mais beaucoup moins de plus les
températures en revanche reste tout
aussi fraîche et pendant que vous
observez les villes qui vous concerne en
tout cas celles qui sont proches de chez
vous jouez en profite pour vous donner
les gelées demain à limoges à clermont
ferrand à reims nancy et strasbourg les
températures dans six villes oscilleront
autour de -2 à -3 degrés il fera deux
degrés ici c'est une petite ville de la
meuse qui s'appelle et un la ville
lumière parce que bien sûr et à la
lumière et puis demain donc nous
traiterons les séverins alors que le
soleil se lèvera
8h18 pour se recoucher à 16h58 prochain
rendez vous d'information édition
spéciale à 22h10 à 23h30 dernier journal
avec aubry et de l'air ensuite basket
aux alentours de 23 heures 55 excellente
soirée sur
antenne 2 pour ma part je vous retrouve
demain à 20 heures avec beaucoup de
plaisir bonsoir ya demain